okay let's uh return back to uh mixed
martial arts
let me ask the ridiculous question of uh
who do you think are the top
three maybe top five greatest fighters
of all time
it's so hard to compare fighters across
generations and maybe on one way to say
it is which metrics
would you put on the table as to measure
what a great fighter is
there was a guy named dioxipus
[Laughter]
in the 4th century yeah and he was such
a badass
that in the olympics in 336 bc no one
even showed up to fight him in the
pancreatic event
nobody even showed up because he was
everybody up and years later he
was retired
and uh this crazy macedonian dude came
there had some dinner for
you know alexander the great everyone's
chilling drinking you know whatever they
were drinking out of their
chalices and this macedonian dude
threatened him and challenged him so
dioccipus said yeah man
we'll throw down and you know they set
the time in the place macedonian dude
comes out like
body armor spear shield all this other
dioxis came out absolutely naked with a
wooden club
and took on this much younger guy beat
the living crap out of him and then put
his foot on his throat
uh and then didn't even kill him in the
show of ultimate power
for the time so i think there's
something about the guy being naked too
is just
extra demeaning extra demeaning yeah
okay
can we rephrase the question then
because those are clearly going to be
some probably forgotten warriors in
history let's take it to like modern day
mixed martial arts in the ufc perhaps
well
just mixed martial arts there who do you
think are the top fighters of all time
what metrics would you consider
in in trying to answer this perhaps
unanswerable question
i think one of the things you want to
think about is a strength of opponent
at the time you fought them so for
example
fighting bj penn in his prime and
beating him is
far different than beating bj penn last
year right
so to say you have a victory over bj
penn is not the same given that the time
frame of when it happened not to take
anything away from anyone was being bj
penn
uh just use that as an example of
someone whose career went into a
different direction
yes i would say
the guy who i think is probably the best
that people are the least familiar with
would be marilla bustamante
and i think he was a guy who was one of
the guys with the first
really good physical build for mma which
i think is
narrow from the chest to the back and
long shoulder to shoulder
and kind of sinewy made out of steel
cable that was a guy who could box
that was a guy who could wrestle and
that was a guy who had great jiu-jitsu
yeah
i wasn't a great kickboxer but at the
time he didn't need it
fought everybody and gave everybody a
run
uh i think he's probably one of those
guys who's
got to be considered yeah there's a few
killers that never
because like why is he not in the
discussion is it because like
i think greatness requires
both the the skill and the opportunity
to meet each other and when you talk
about a fighter the other thing
that really a good fighter needs to
become great is a foil
yeah and so many fighters don't have a
foil
that's one of the biggest attractions i
think of early mike tyson's career
he didn't have a foil he had no one
driving him and by the time he did by
the time he had a foil in holyfield
his career was in a different place but
he he's one of the greats of all time
he never really had a foil so his
greatness was
in the un unparalleled destruction
of like nobody right well not you know
uh of lesser opponents right and so when
people
uh debate the you know the level of
greatness of mike tyson that's one of
the things they say like he didn't fight
a lot of killers in their prime
i think you've obviously got to say
in that conversation i have a really
difficult time
keeping george st pierre out of the
conversation
uh only because he was able to beat you
with anything he could he could
out jab you he could out wrestle you and
he could he could submit you
the problem i have with fedor is his
career
also took a drastic turn towards the end
and when he was fighting in pride he was
doing a lot more grappling
and then he just started casting that
overhand right at people
and his game kind of changed at that
point uh he can't take anything away
from his greatness but
at that time the great heavyweights were
not really
uh in fighting in pride and they didn't
really exist yet and by the time he
fought a really good one fabricio verdum
he did get submitted there does does his
later
performance color our your and our
perception
of his greatness like in general about
fighters
not mine but i'm someone who's like
intimately involved in the sport
but it colors everyone else's same with
anderson silva like i don't think
anderson still doesn't want to fight in
like seven years or something or he's
like
one like that's a guy who in his prime
was one of the best fighters is he in
the top five for you
i think he's probably in a top five yeah
greater striker of all time or no
in mma and mixed martial arts and mixed
martial arts
that's a tough question the greatest mma
striker of all time because like the
timing
the we were talking about foot sweeps
right yeah who makes it look easier
and uh anderson zilla i think in an
incredibly short sample of his prime
it's got to be anderson silva and i
think you have to consider
discussing leota machida for his
unbelievable
manipulation of distance yeah which is
something that people don't really talk
too much about
in terms of fighting unless you're
someone in the sport yeah the
his his use of distance and the ability
to like
what we call pop out like and make you
miss by one
inch so that he could follow your fist
back in as you retract it and hit you
over the top
that that's a thing of beauty
anderson silva when he became a counter
striker when he got to his prime in ufc
that was a thing of beauty that was the
thing of beauty um so i think definitely
those two guys and
mirila bustamante's got to be the third
guy
they're just so many good guys now so
where do you put
in terms of metrics do you mention gsp
and national silva i think they have a
large number of defenses of a title
is that important to you like this kind
of consistent
domination no because it's too much it's
easily easily manipulated by the people
making money off the fights
so there's a great quote one time uh
when ufc was coming to prominence
and uh vince mcmahon from the wwe he
said
you know the difference between what we
do and what uh ufc does
is that when we have a superstar i can
make sure he stays on top until he's no
longer a superstar because we have
predetermined results
the ufc can't do that because they're
actually having fights well
it's true and false you can't do that
but you can give
your superstars the most favorable
matchups to keep them on top for the
longest
so people always talk about title
defenses as if the guy they're fighting
the challenger
is always the person most deserving of
the shot and it's just not true so i
don't put that much stock in it
you